today I've got something so incredible
to show you these are the new Xbox
minecraft controllers I am so excited
and I am even more surprised because
this show it was like Thor and I didn't
even know I didn't know I had absolutely
no idea so huge thank you to Xbox
because I don't think you guys
understand it's just made my day my
month my year or probably like next five
years
pigs are my absolute favorite animal
first of all second of all when I was
playing Minecraft back in the day on my
gaming channel I was doing a whole
series of creating a pig Palace here we
go all of you come on come hey look what
I have well you know my character he'll
be stupid
join me it was so much fun it was
probably one of my most favorite series
ever I'm sure some of you guys remember
if you do a comment below a pig emoji
microsoft also announced a Minecraft
Xbox one s console and it looks freaking
great it basically looks like a block of
dirt and on the back it has redstone
circuitry so essentially that's with
power in your Xbox the Minecraft console
will be out on October 3rd it's 399 each
one of these controllers are also sold
separately so if you don't need a new
Xbox
these ones are each $74.99 but I'm sure
a lot of you guys are probably holding
up the new Xbox one X what do you guys
think of the project Scorpio version I'm
excited because I just want to be able
to call my xbox one X project Scorpio
because I still keep calling it that I'm
sure most of you guys are here for this
unboxing so let's just get to it because
I'm so excited I don't want to cut the
head
I got a couple blocks I don't have any
scissors how do I not amuses I have
nothing I lose this I'm gonna use this
Wally to cut this hey Wally do your job
I open it the wrong way
oh man okay hold on let's redo it I
clean up the habit it's beautiful Wow
take a look at this I love the color and
on the back it's got this little
squiggly which is to signify the little
pig's tail this thing is so great it is
perfectly designed ok now let's open up
the creeper 1 which is also a very very
good luck sorry that Wally man it just
looks so incredible and look at the back
it's got a little tens here where you
put the batteries these are really
really well-designed I'm a huge fan
I even got pixelated text on the button
well I guess it's time for a slow-mo
montage
[Music]
[Applause]
let me know what you guys think of these
controllers I'm super super excited
about it I honestly was so surprised
that these came in the mail because they
were just announced a few days ago a
huge thank you to Xbox and Microsoft for
seriously making me like the happiest I
feel like I'm a child I feel like I'm a
child if you just opened up their
present on Christmas Day it's not even
Christmas it's not even holidays on my
birthday
thank you so let me know which one of
these controllers is your favorite
obviously you clearly know mine and
where do you guys mostly play Minecraft
you play on your phone do you play on PC
do you play on Mac you play on an iPad
you play on xbox one of the things that
I'm most excited about is being able to
play cross-platform so no matter what
platform you're on you'll actually be
able to play with your friends and that
is was getting me super interested in
starting a server again I know I've
talked about it a bunch and I feel like
a lot of you guys might be into that
judging by the comments and the replies
and the tweets and the emails that I've
been getting you guys actually seem
pretty into it so I'll keep you posted
I do minecraft maybe making a return
which means I'm gonna have to do a pig
Palace again it's gonna be Pig Palace
2017 edition I'll see you guys later
thanks again for watching and that's it
I'm gonna go put batteries in this thing
I'll see you later my babies my precious
[Music]
[Applause]